um
something happened in the last couple of
weeks some information
that's out in the universe that has um
opened my mind up and at first i was
excited about it
but then
i changed my point of view about it and
i'm going to tell you what it is
ji young
do you know what that is
you know what the muppets are sesame
street yeah i
know enough
they created their first oh i saw i saw
on the news i just didn't know his name
was young it's a woman it's a female oh
i didn't know her name was jion it's a
young
asian
muppet is it
muppet right that's what they call them
i thought because aquafina posted it
yeah you could call jiyong and i don't
like it i'll tell you why
because puppeteers are these old
white dudes
oh god
hear me out we watch a documentary i
know and i don't want to hit you see
these old white dudes with their hands
inside a young female what is this
woody allen's house
[Laughter]
now i brought that whole thing up so i
could tell that one joke i have a
question
and that's it i'm trying to think of my
head we're done yeah i mean when that
this news came out you knew who got hard
mitch mcconnell i mean
i'm like i might as well get a new one
they're making new ones um no but i
don't like i have a question my
follow-up question to that is like
would you would the person holding the
puppet have to be asian how does it work
anyways are they still puppeteers behind
these
do you think it's animatronic
are there strings and sticks that hold
them up these days
i'm not much of a puppeteer but i'm
pretty sure in this situation humans
there is a hand in the [ __ ] are they
in the credits the
problem i've never
you know
i watch sesame street all the time and i
never wait for the end credits
like i've always wanted to know what the
prop guy was like
wait what's what's that famous puppeteer
who's uh the black man who does elmo yes
yeah he's the best what's his name
uh let me see he's the greatest of all
time to do it
elmo puppeteer is kevin clash yeah kevin
clash
legend there's a documentary about kevin
klein we cried i love that dude um so my
question is we don't know who's
puppeteering the asian american muppet
or jiong well i'm about to make a call
to sesame street after this podcast and
go make sure it's either
you mean i'd love to see an asian
puppeteer
that wouldn't make me feel uncomfortable
if kevin clash wanted to do it would you
be cool with that yeah i'd be fine with
that yeah i i would be fine if you get
it [ __ ] hands inside that little
[Music]
little asian muppet
big ass thick ass [ __ ] he's
workshopping birthdays
his workshop i'm working on go let him
go i'm just workshopping a pit baby your
hands would be too small to be a
puppeteer you'd have to use your green
foot
all right no you know it's like her
slams as of late
it's either foot or my fatness
foot and fatness there's only one time
that i called you fat one
there's this one picture of you in
mexico
oh my god and i was like [ __ ]
oh you you mean the photo that when i
just arrived there i was just sitting on
a chair and i was leaning back and my
belly was out and and i was exposing my
belly so that you could create laughter
in the room
it wasn't really that fat
i don't know i just think you're eating
like [ __ ] but wait do you really do what
were your last yeah your last three
meals healthy today
healthy was today today oh like healthy
the meal healthy was today yeah okay
what did you have for brekkie i didn't
have anything which is a good thing
ultimate fasting yeah your body's
resetting
right and today i was driving down the
street
and i go dude oprah
i'm a big oprah fan by the way
i love her
her leadership